another terror attack in London now
Durney the morning rush hour a terrorist
set off a homemade bomb on a subway
train injuring 29 and causing passengers
to flee in panic a manhunt is currently
underway for the suspect and officials
have raised the terror threat level to
critical in the UK meaning another
attack may be imminent
president Trump reacted on Twitter
calling for a quote larger tougher and
more specific travel ban here in the
United States and said this earlier
today I want to say that our hearts and
prayers go out to the people of London
who suffered a vicious terrorist attack
today I spoke with a wonderful woman
British prime minister Theresa May this
morning and relate America's deepest
sympathy as well as our absolute
commitment to eradicating the terrorists
from our planet radical Islamic
terrorism it will be eradicated believe
me okay we're reminded Greg of the
differences between the prior
administration and President Trump and
also trying to come out very strong
using those words again as radical
Islamic terrorism calling him out
calling for the eradication of them and
this messaging coming obviously on the
heels of some criticism for the
president - on his immigration policy it
seems like he's kind of reaching out
again to his base why the I mean this is
what he's known for but I just to focus
on the actual attack that it's another
example of why we have to harden soft
targets because we will always be
vulnerable and that includes people
people have to start thinking and in
training we train for earthquakes we
were kids you know we've trained for
mass shootings as adolescents the crowd
panicked here and they they trampled a
little boy and they they hit a pregnant
women in the or we pushed her over this
these are natural responses what happens
when people panic but we need to and
this is how terrorism work it creates
fear people panic and it makes it worse
but we need to train and harden the
individuals so that they know how to
react to things like that
a lot of people call this a failed
attempt because no one died but that
every every one of these attacks is
successful because every attack that HAP
terrorists learn something from it and
they adjust their techniques so the next
time the attack is more deadly this
could have been just a dry run I think
that what's necessary I think these poor
the the officials and experts are over
overwhelmed I think they need more bomb
sniffing dogs for two reasons they're
efficient and and inexpensive at
sniffing out bombs and terrorists hate
them because they can't get to paradise
if a dog is in their presence when they
die I learned that today I hope it's
right this terror attack and Monday was
the anniversary of 9/11 it comes around
every year it gives us an opportunity to
think about where we are in the war on
terror and I I think this attack
highlights as do the ones we've seen in
Western Europe in recent months that
really since 2001
everything about the terrorist threat
has changed the way that the United
States responds to the terrorist threat
and tries to combat it has changed the
battlefield was largely now in
cyberspace the face of these terrorist
organizations has changed hands many
times we've seen organizations like Isis
rise and fall it's not defeated yet but
it's much reduced the thing that remains
the same and that we're still not
getting right is the is the impact that
radical ideology still has on large
population areas across the world and I
think that's an area where the United
States in spite of our incredible
military and intelligence prowess is
still not doing enough we've got this I
think it's called the global engagement
center at the State Department it's
underfunded its understaffed these are
the people that are responsible for
fighting Isis and radical Islamic
terrorism online this is where we need
to be putting more money more time and
attention more public political
attention I don't understand why we're
not doing that because it's attacks like
this that are so low-budget then really
highlight as long as people are
attracted to that ideology we're not
solving the problem
okay got it all right so Jesse I'm you
know obviously thoughts and prayers go
out to the people in London it's just
that anxiety we weren't worrying when
you wake up in the morning because
something happened could you be the
person
or you know or your family member in the
wrong place at the wrong time people
relying on public transportation which
now as we've seen has become one of
these soft targets you know unless they
have people on there that are armed and
there's some kind of physical deterrent
to this type of conduct it seems like
this is the direction that they're going
in yeah
Great Britain's our best ally but they
have to get much tougher and I think in
Trump's own way he was trying to tell
them that no American city would
tolerate this kind of repeated carnage
which we've seen over there in London
the majority of Americans agree with
what President Trump is pushing and
after this in the aftermath here he that
we want stricter internet crackdowns on
jihadi propaganda we want to be less
politically correct we want more
surveillance and I think 60% of the
American public wants the travel ban so
that's all clear he faced a little
criticism today when he pivoted from the
attack to the travel ban and I don't
blame him because all politicians seized
on big moments in order to push their
agenda every time there was a domestic
terror attack in this country President
Obama pushed gun control when you see
hurricanes happen politicians put that
push the global warming agenda so I
don't blame him for that he also said
that Scotland Yard had their eyes on
these people and caught a little heat
from Theresa May the prime minister you
know he also said that the London Bridge
attack was a terror attack before
Scotland Yard had called it that and he
was right so I'm sure he has great
intelligence from our intelligence
officials and the guy shoots for the hip
from the hip and we just have to get
used to it you've mentioned to Greg
earlier we've had eight years of the
president United States wait sometimes
two days after an attack to call it a
terror attack and if a guy is yelling
Allah Akbar you know he's from Syria and
he's stabbing people President Obama
still really wouldn't say Islamic terror
president Trump will say it this is why
we elected him we wanted someone who was
tough on terrorism you know what in four
years public might not like that we
could have Pocahontas as president but
right now we have President Trump and I
think the media has to get used to this
kind of tough talk all right so you know
one gun of your thoughts it reflections
on what's happened is that in how it
that's us here well just er start by
saying I think it was 29 people were
injured thank God it wasn't any no one
was seriously injured most of it flash
burns from the explosion in the subway
and the second thing to say is that with
regard to Trump he was rebuked by
Theresa May I mean she said this is not
helpful to London police said not
helpful and then you had the National
Security Advisor HR McMaster come out
and he was like cleaning up after the
parade said oh the president's just
speaking generally he didn't have any
specific information so what we have
here to my mind is you know as jessie
was saying we know our president you
know we love president drunk but
goodness gracious
he speaks impetuously at times it's
almost like he's just quick to fire and
you gotta think it's not a matter of the
press Jessie it's a matter of our top
ally a key intelligence ally saying what
do you do you are putting us in our
putting lives at risk by indicating to
the terrorists that we have them in our
sights or that we know the network that
are connected with we're not there yet
we're not putting that out we're working
this case this is a live investigation
and so there's some you know problem
there with that in my opinion but I
think the biggest problem here is one in
which you see president Trump so quick
to shoot at anything that fits his as
Jessie was saying agenda I don't see
that when it comes to white supremacists
down in Charlottesville oh no he doesn't
slow to say anything about that and this
business about saying radical Islamic
terror
that's not solving the problem solving
the problem and Trump said this today by
the way folks we've got to do better on
the Internet picking up on what Jillian
was saying much better we harden targets
but we got to fight the ideology that's
the cancer could I just respond to there
to cultural points here a this is a far
bigger bigger problem than anything that
happened in Charlottesville this is a
this is a worldwide ideology and the
ideology when you're talking about
it's a collision between bitter loners
and what's in the Western world it used
to be that people didn't see how others
lived if you were in Pakistan you never
knew what the Kardashians were because
there was no way that
you knew that our Western world is
colliding with people who hate that so
that it's not necessarily Isis ideology
it's just the fact that they hate the
West the other thing too is that you're
supposed to as an individual say
something after seeing something
especially when the authorities cannot
protect you 100% of the time as you can
see they stopped a lot of plots they
weren't they weren't able to stop this
one but they stopped a lot the point is
this if they can't protect you somehow
you have to protect yourself by saying
something when you see something however
there's a cultural blockade there that
deems you Islamophobic if you say
something when you see something and you
might be wrong if you are wrong you are
screwed and so when you're on a subway
or when you're on a bus and you see
something and you go I want to say
something but you know what I don't want
to end up on a blog being ripped apart I
don't want to lose my job so I'm not
gonna we have to make it okay to say
things and one you know that but I say
why would you say that this is somehow
bigger it seems to me when you talk
about crazed poisonous ideologies
whether it's the white supremacists or
the I don't want its Lobby how many
people have neo-nazis killed in the last
ten years Oh last ten years oh you want
as long as radicalism is everywhere you
know which is worse yeah that's I don't
think that helped it once started torn
apart on blogs Greg can help talk you
through the blog therapist meantime Juan
and Gregory to go to their separate
corners for a little timeout